- In the woods of a peaceful island
off the coast of Portland, Maine,
the concrete remains of a massive
World War II-era gun battery
are hiding in plain sight.
I'm Jessica Hester,
staff writer at Atlas Obscura,
and we're going inside Battery Steele.
Today, visitors think of
coastal Maine as a getaway.
It's a place where I kayaked
and ate lobster rolls.
But there was a time when the coast
was a border that needed defending.
In the 1940s, the military thought
the war might come to American shores.
To defend Casco Bay and its shipyards,
the Navy installed nets
to capture submarines.
Their tools could detect
something as small
as fish swimming by.
The island's military history museum
has a huge collection of photos
showing what it looked like at the time.
You can see barracks,
observation towers,
and Battery Steele,
whose huge guns pointed out at the water.
The military legacy is still
visible on the island today,
if you know where to look.
Any explorer can visit Battery Steele,
but it takes some work to find it.
It was built to be hidden
and it still kind of is.
The low concrete building
looks both forgotten
and a little futuristic.
It's overgrown
and seems to just kind of
rise up out of the earth.
I couldn't tell how big it was
or exactly where it ended or began,
but it's giant.
Hundreds of feet long,
just camouflaged by rocks and trees.
Feeling around in the darkness,
it was hard for me to
imagine Battery Steele
being frantic or crowded.
It was just so quiet and desolate.
The light near the entrance
vanishes almost right away,
and it's kind of like walking into a tomb.
It was a little unsettling.
You don't know exactly where you are.
There are these far-off
sounds of dripping water.
And you don't know what
your flashlight will find.
It took a while to walk
from one end to the other,
and to poke around in the side rooms
where the control panels were.
I wondered how long it would have taken
to load one of those 60-foot guns
with 2,000-pound projectiles.
Even if they were never fired at a ship,
they looked terrifying.
Before the guns were scrapped in 1948,
locals sometimes climbed on them
like they were boulders or trees.
Today, the walls are marked
up with murals and graffiti.
Some residents eventually turned
old barracks into cottages
and they made them cheerful
by painting stuff on the sides like plants
and windowsills.
A number of other structures burned down,
but if you wander around the woods
in the middle of the island,
you might come across an observation tower
peeking just above the tree line.
It's easy to imagine climbing up there
and keeping watch out toward the horizon.
You'll also see a couple
of little white buildings
with narrow slats right at eye level.
People would have hunkered down in there,
standing guard,
ready for an enemy attack.
Visitors come because it's beautiful
and peaceful.
And the water's a big part of that.
On the shore, you could go
all day without noticing
the relics from when people thought
it was a dangerous place to be.
It's strange to think I
could have missed all of it,
if I hadn't wandered into the woods
and gotten a little lost.
And I never would have
known what I could've found
if I just looked a little closer.
Thanks so much for watching.
Subscribe to our channel to
see more videos like this one
and hop into the comments
to tell us which military
ruins we should visit next.